officials from Israel the Palestinian
Authority the U.S Jordan and Egypt are
meeting in the city of Aqaba in Jordan
they're discussing ways of de-escalating
the recent tensions in the occupied West
Bank but many Palestinians say the
global Community wants to maintain
Israel's military occupation in Abraham
reports
to miss growing Palestinian
armed groups the latest example was seen
as thousands demonstrated across the
occupied West Bank at midnight
responding to a call by the Lion's Den
armed hope
11 Palestinians were killed in an
Israeli raid on the city of nablis on
Wednesday some were fighters from the
group
now Palestinian officials have flown to
Jordan to attend the security Summit
with Israel organized by the U.S
Egyptian and Jordanian officials are
also there
the meeting on Sunday is an attempt to
de-escalate growing tensions and
re-establish Palestinian Security
Control in nablis and Janine two cities
where Fighters are operating
the Americans don't want a full-blown
escalation that would destabilize the
region at a time they and the rest of
the world are busy with Ukraine and its
ramifications the worst that could
happen is we Implement their plan to
push the PA security to take over from
the Israeli occupation that would lead
to Civil War
Palestine depends on International Aid
and a large sum of the money it gets
goes to the security forces
most graduates from this Military
Academy end up joining the ranks of
Palestinian Authority Security Forces
even when Aid has fluctuated support for
the security establishment hasn't
stopped
critics say such heavy International
Investment in the security forces this
empowers Palestinians and many question
coordination between the Palestinian
Authority and Israel on security
nearly 30 percent of international Aid
to the Palestinian Authority goes
towards security when the Palestinian
Authority was established the main goal
of international Aid was to keep the
peace process going but this has changed
over the years and many say that the
goal now is to ensure stability
while many world leaders are calling for
de-escalation intention Palestinians say
they're missing the obvious problem
Israel's military occupation and without
addressing that they say any other
discussions will only prolong it
the occupied Westbank
I'll just hear a senior political
analyst Muhammad Bouchard is joining me
now in this studio good to have you with
us as always with regard to this meeting
is this meeting that the Palestinian
Authority had to go to did it really
have no other option
well it does have options
and that's what uh most Palestinian
factions most Palestinian parties
much of the Palestinian public opinion
has demanded that it does not go
to such a meeting that it's preferable
for the Palestinian Authority to be more
in touch intact with its own people
rather than with the demands of Israel
and the United States
but the Palestinian Authority for a long
time has been hostage
to a diplomatic process that's basically
run from Washington
and because of the fear that Israel is
uh
increasing its repression in the
occupied territories increasing its
illegal settlements
Palestine feels that it needs to go back
to the United States
it tried the United Nations as you know
but that did not work very well the
United States has promised that it will
bring Israel to the table but instead of
discussing the end of occupation we are
discussing securing the the occupation
instead of discussing a return to
diplomacy we are discussing the return
to security and instead of discussing
peace
now we are discussing coexistence with
the military occupation you're talking
about the the pushback that the
Palestinian Authority has had about the
fact that it is going to go to this
meeting particularly of course some some
of the Armed groups that we we uh we
know about how much is a is it a risk to
the Palestinian Authority itself to
actually be making this decision to go
to the uh to this meeting I think it's
quite risky especially now that there
are more and more
armed groups within Palestinian refugee
camps within the Palestinian cities like
Janine nablis and others as well as
refugee camps in the south
and I think those
uh it's going to be very hard for the
Palestinian Authority to take control of
without a lot of Palestinian casualties
a lot of Palestinian divisions and
suffering and so on so forth but what is
required in the sakaba Summit is for the
Palestinians to take on the security of
the occupation so that Israel doesn't do
it itself the only way Netanyahu is
going to accept that Israeli forces
don't go in and kill more Palestinians
in Janine and nablas as for the
Palestinian thought to do it itself but
the presidential Authority would be
quite foolish if it will be responsible
for a Palestinian Civil War
in order to defend Israel but by the way
just to put that in perspective and it's
important for our viewers around the
world because I'm sure no one or hardly
anyone remembers that there was an Aqaba
meeting 20 years ago
this year
20 years ago back the summer there was
an acaba meeting hosted by King Abdullah
but who attended that meeting
President Bush
prime minister Sharon it was a summit of
leaders discussing a vision of two-state
solution
that was then today we have mid and low
level technical rights and security
advisors
trying to implement trying to reinforce
Israeli occupation
so you can imagine from 20 years back to
now how Dreadful the situation has
devolved into
um
senior political analyst as always thank
you very much indeed